[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's mike triplett espn
nfl nation reporter covering the saints
i saw where
taysom hill gave himself a bb plus after
the game what grade would you give him
mike
well it depends are we are we grading on
the curve of the expectations that were
set for him uh
then it would be uh then it'd probably
be an eight plus but that's fair
um he missed a couple of throws uh
actually completed a 44 yarder on one of
the throws he missed but then he had a
couple that would have made it even more
special he completed a 57-yard touchdown
pass
that was called back by holding but look
i think this was proof
um not that he is the next steve young
not that he's even going to be the
saints next starter after drew brees
retires
but that he's not just a gimmick and
that he can be a pocket passer
with running ability sean payton wasn't
making all this stuff up
or just trying to show off when he kept
saying he believed he could win with
jason keller quarterback
was sean payton gloating post game not
as much as we all would have liked i
think but
at least one retweet of roddy white the
former falcons receiver who i i think
when sean payton retweeted that cold
take he was sort of
uh choosing the one that would represent
all of the cold takes that he would be
up all night if he was looking for all
of them
i didn't think they were going to go
with taysom hill i just thought that
jameis winston made the most sense and i
i'm not rooting against taysom hill or
the experiment there
it just felt like maybe jameis winston
under the tutelage of sean payton and
drew brees
was going to be able to manage a game a
little bit more intelligently and not
take chances there
what does taysom hill like is taysom
hill is this week to week or is taysom
hill there as long as
drew is out well it's hard to envision
them doing anything week to week now
they're not
afraid of some subterfuge they obviously
kept this a secret as long as they could
last week so
it wouldn't be the most surprising thing
i've ever seen if there is a a
you know out of nowhere jameis winston
game plan one day but i think the more
likely uh is that they stick with jason
hill because look
this wasn't a huge surprise in the grand
scheme of things i mean they did just
pay taysom hill two years 21 million
dollars in the off season a couple
months before they ever even signed
jameis winston in the first place
and they've been talking for years about
taysom hill being next in line it
actually
you can make an argument would have been
unfair to have winston leapfrog him this
is his fourth year in the system and
he's been waiting his turn and peyton
said he deserves this
the only reason i thought they might
stick with winston
is because i thought it might be a
harder mid-season transition to take
some pill i thought maybe it would have
taken more than one week
to game plan for for jason pill change
the offense around him
but i think two things happened one we
saw that sean payton
has had these tyson hill ideas in his
mind for a long time
there are a lot of chasing hill plays in
the playbook and two he was more of a
pocket passer than anyone expected there
were
a small amount of design runs uh and he
stood back in the pocket quite a bit now
one of those touchdown runs was on a
design pass play that broke down
which is an element he brings but
they're not just relying on his legs
when he runs this off but what i didn't
understand mike
is that sean payton basically said look
we have to find out what we have and
take some hill
at this point you still don't know what
you have in taysom hill
well not necessarily and you know he
didn't come out and say that openly i
think that was a source attributed to
him but
um i think it's a combination of two
things it's it's
their belief that he could potentially
replace drew brees as a starter is
genuine
um so if you or someone who really
believes that why wouldn't he be the guy
that you put
into this situation you can't just keep
putting him on hold
and keep him as a maybe they need a
starter this week if they believe in
taysom hill why shouldn't he be the
starter
what's the the update on drew brees the
latest he came out and he told ed werder
that he
is optimistic he can come back after the
three weeks he's required to to miss
with injured reserve
so many unknowns with this injury you
can't just look up oh yeah you know
punctured lungs always take four weeks
you can't do that i'm sure there'll be a
lot of medical updates but we do know
that he's going to be determined to come
back and that optimism
uh that he expressed after talking to a
lot of doctors makes it seem realistic
he could do that
uh before the regular season is over why
does this injury get worse it feels like
every other day like they've added
has another broken rib taking place here
he's got 11. mike well you know he wants
to
do everything to the fullest but do you
think he was going to come out and and
say he broke 10 ribs
but that number where brady couldn't
catch him but do you think that
all of the all of this happened on that
one sack
it felt like he was prior to this right
he's been open about
the latest reporting or what he told
edward was
that all eight of them were on the left
side which was a previous injury and
three of them were on the right side
which was the new injury now he had been
playing through that and playing pretty
well
he'd been on the injury report the
shoulder injury so he had obviously been
feeling some discomfort
uh but until all the swelling went down
they didn't actually go in and count
each rib fracture it's great to talk to
you mike uh
certainly got a big story there with uh
taysom hill and then the return of the
saints i thought the defensive line won
that game i thought the pressure they
put on matt ryan
uh was really the difference maker uh in
my opinion
that's three weeks in a row for the
defense i mean you saw him on sunday
night football 38-3 over tampa they were
playing great
and that was the case last year when
teddy everybody remembers teddy
bridgewater went 5-0 as the saint
starter
defense was playing a big role in that
as well thank you mike
thank you that's mike triplett espn nfl
nation reporter covering the saints the
saints now eight and two and then you
have
the big game with the buccaneers coming
up against the rams